[Applause]
hello CNN
we're back here with tablet magazine
columnist and author of Secret City
Jamie kirchik lieutenant governor of
Virginia Winsome Earl Sears and the
Republican governor of New Hampshire
Chris dununu quite a lineup here tonight
and people want to know these questions
that they write in okay this is for
governor sununu what do you make of
Biden's decision to make South Carolina
the first Democratic Primacy right now
your governor of New Hampshire that was
always and still is the Republican first
no and the Democrat I'm sorry Joe we're
going first I don't care what the Dem
the Democrat Party doesn't dictate who
goes first the state of New Hampshire
does no but that no that's not saying
that the Democrat changed theirs no they
didn't so the Democrats tried but New
Hampshire's Democrat primary will still
go first because again our law says
we're going to go first and this is
Biden's real problem because he's left a
huge opening for someone to come into
New Hampshire uh campaign there strong
with some Name ID and uh and and charge
through essentially by the way South
Carolina doesn't have a first in the
nation primary they they dictate Trump
didn't have one in 20. they just said
Trump's the win so Biden has effectively
moved the first of the nation tried to
move it from New Hampshire to a state
that won't even hold it they'll just say
you're the incumbent you're the winner
so it's actually a horrible
miscalculation on his part but I'm sorry
Joe we're going first well okay now
now you announced on our show tonight
that you're running for president
let's see let's see what happens
not in so many words but I did look my
wife is is texting me as we speak okay
but New Hampshire I mean that's a wash
for you because you're from New
Hampshire so that primary is meaningless
for you because if you don't win it then
oh my God you can't even win your home
state and if you do win it it means
nothing no no if you win it won't if I
were to win New Hampshire it would be
you're not you didn't win by enough and
if you lose it you're totally toasted
it's actually a disadvantage yeah yeah
okay now for you lieutenant governor
Sears what's a realistic way to approach
immigration reform
Heavens how about doing it the right way
and doing it the legal way I mean my dad
had to wait in line wait his turn sign
all kinds of documents prove who he was
I mean you've got to know who's coming
into the country we are a nation of laws
and if he had to do it everybody's got
to do it that's the law I'm sorry okay
no don't apologize that's the right
answer you nailed it oh no I'm not
apologize okay
um governor should be doing we'd be
doing more to secure our northern border
to prevent Northern underlying to
prevent the trafficking of drugs and
Canadians what and Canadian very
dangerous so a northern border crossing
is up 800
in just the last quarter from Canada
yeah so we're doing kind of our part A
lot of the states are open it's a very
unprotected border but it's nothing like
the southern border of course but yeah
you have to protect the northern border
as well Canada has agreements with about
five different countries you don't even
need visas I think a Honduras El
Salvador they fly to Canada and then
they walk across we have them walking
across through the woods in New
Hampshire of course our longest border
is with Canada yeah another critique of
your state as a primary state is that
it's not diverse so it doesn't really
look not diverse look like America we
have the highest voter turnout in the
country South Carolina's diversity look
South Carolina has about 15 percent
voter turnout what's the point of
diversity if you don't let anybody vote
if nobody comes out to participate we
have Rich we have poor we have black we
have white it doesn't matter everyone in
New Hampshire participates in the
process well I mean I'll take I'll put
my diversity against South Carolina's
any day when you actually look at who's
actually voting and participating right
the only black you have there is a bear
oh
yeah
it's a very white thing no no sure of
course okay oh yeah okay but I'm just
saying but that's that's what isn't it
didn't you participates is it about
actually having a primary like I said
the Democrats likely aren't even going
to hold the primary in South Carolina so
what's the point of diversity if you
don't let people participate I mean they
say that we we subvert the vote by
asking people for an ID they subvert the
vote by not even letting them show up
I mean that's the reality you're facing
here so that's why we're the best at the
first in the nation primary I'm the high
voter participation the voter turnout
local control and here's the most
important part I can't help you build
yeah I'm not following this argument I'm
from Massachusetts and we used to refer
to New Hampshire as Kentucky and New
England
so that's
really really
that's not nice
give me a break why why is New Hampshire
the fastest growing the Northeast it's
not fair that's come on I didn't say I
agreed with it it's just that was what
we used to say
speaking of peak Caucasian
um
perfect segue for this question why was
the public so captivated by Gwyneth
Paltrow's trial this week is it
does the panel think Justice was served
does the panel care he said she said
yeah I mean really you know rich people
fighting it out you know I'm not in that
here's the only go ahead
he was an orthodontist if I'm not
mistaken Optometry optometrist retired
optometrist okay
meaning well I
think
you were like Perry Mason I have the
evidence and then nothing what's the
significance he was an optometrist Matt
says it all if he was an orthodontist I
had terrible memories of orthodontistry
as a teenager like like many of us have
had and I would have sided with her
instinctively on that but he wasn't an
orthodontist so it doesn't matter I
think I think she was inspired by Johnny
Depp no in this way Johnny Depp was just
not going to take it he was like now we
don't know what goes on in the marriage
although actually we do know went on to
that marriage because they testified to
it in court you cut off my finger you
in the bed you know okay oh
marriage it sounds great anyway
um but I I think Gwyneth was the same
thing she was like this was only cost
her three hundred thousand dollars she's
worth million she could have just paid
it off and she said I am not going to
let a guy just hold me up I'm going to
fight it I'm you know we just can't have
this situation in this country which we
do have where people can accuse you of
anything and it's just easier to pay off
she said I don't care if it's just one
dollar that's assuming she didn't do it
I mean who knows what happened there was
no video you know we're a video of
society but they're skiing exactly I
mean I don't know who knows one of them
collided into the other yeah to each
other somebody sued somebody else this
is America we Sue and then we see what
happens that's what I'm saying this is
where I'll give Gwyneth a lot of credit
do you see after the verdict came down
she went over Pat him on the shoulder
and said I wish you well that's a boss
move that is a boss move on her part
because it basically says nice try yeah
yeah when you win it's easy to do yeah
it's nice to be nice I mean I've never
understood she got her dollar skiing you
know I I would never ski what a stupid
sport you know oh here we go
Brown
the last week I was shoveling my walkway
and and I got excited I came out to
California and you have a whole
different flavor of snowflake out here
so I'm dealing with that
I'll bring his King sometime I was just
gonna say anything
[Laughter]
how many writers snowflakes jokes I'm
going out to California
speaking of which another great segue
California governor Gavin Newsom
announced that he plans
oh yeah I read this to travel to states
where freedom is most under attack I
don't know would this strategy help
Democrat I I I I I don't know years ago
the California legislature banned State
money going to travel to States that had
so-called anti-lgbtq laws so you
couldn't have the sports teams you
couldn't have state officials going to
other states that had controversial laws
and just a couple days ago the one of
the leading legislators who supported
this said it's not working and we have
to repeal this because there's too much
business going on across the country we
have to travel and it would lead to a
Civil War I mean if you can't even and
we're also making it very personal
remember the Civil War what it was
called the war between the states we're
making it very personal between states
like your state is
is kind of purple now right I mean it's
a little more red than purple but yeah
we always get something yeah right I
mean well here's the thing he's talking
about Freedom less states that are less
free isn't he the guy who told everybody
they had to stay home during covet and
then he went to some lobbyist dinner
with what 25 of his best friends so they
were hanging out having a good time this
was the number one lockdown State that's
a true does he have a mirror oh yes he
does because we've seen his hair
oh Gavin the knives are out here
on the people okay he owned that he
shouldn't have gone out that yeah he
shouldn't have locked down the state
among the among the political
peccadillos I I put it about thousandths
down on the list it wasn't it wasn't his
finest moment but really come on if
that's all you got on him no how about
the school how about the millions
the list on Gavin is quite long okay if
you have time put it this way
Republicans would love to run against
Governors
ticket
I can't run time before anybody says
anything about immigration again
remember I wasn't born here so you can't
run no then it's the new number and
that's why you're so delightfully honest
I thank you all for being here gotta go
time for a commercial